We're raising our girls to be perfect,
andwe're raising our boys to be brave.
Most girls are taught to avoid risk and failure.
Their taught to smile pretty,
play it safe,
get all A's.
Boys, on the other hand, are
taught toplay rough.
And by the time they're adults,
whether they're negotiating a raise or
evenasking someone out on a date,
they're habituated to take risk after risk.
They're rewardedfor it.
An HP report found that
men will apply for a job
if they meet only 60 percent
of the qualifications,
but women,
women will apply only if
they meet 100 percent.
The braverydeficit is why women
are underrepresented in STEM,
in C-suites, in boardrooms, in Congress,
andpretty much everywhere you look.
We have to socialize our girls to
be comfortable withimperfection,
and we've got to do it now.